et on est dans l'émotion légitime on est
dans le quasi pathos mais faire de la
politique c'est aussi impérial terre
faire de la politique ça consiste à
nouer une relation aussi profonde coco 6
avec un électorat et il est clair qu'il
faut pas rater ce genre d'occasions
parce qu'avec la mort de johnny une
grande partie du pays est en état de
choc et les mots que prononce les hommes
politiques on s'en souviendra
on se souviendra de l'homme politique
qui aura été un peu froid aujourd'hui
qui n'aura pas été au diapason du pays
donc c'est important ce qu'ils disent
mais en même temps on voit bien les
échelons de génération par exemple les
mains de la crau ce sont des phrases
très ciselée mais qui ont été
construites
on voit un peu par un service de
communication raffarin on voit une
émotion réelle
il insiste sur le fait qu'il a été au
contact physique de johnny hallyday est
la relation que les français ont avec
johnny hallyday
c'est une relation physique fait une
relation c'était la puissance physique
incarner la vie le don absolue de soi
sur scène et donc et donc c'est très
important si c'est très important c'est
un moment politique important aussi